merci Monsieur serveur pour un rappel au
règlement
sur quel fondement monsieur le service
vous voyez nous constatons que
ceux qui sont minoritaires aujourd'hui
utilisent finalement quelques
réglementations obstructives pour ne pas
admettre qu'ils sont minoritaires ici
dans l'hémicycle
et
je vous regarde chez un collègue vous
avez le sourire aux lèvres
vous êtes satisfait de vous réjouis
vous êtes content d'avoir pu trouver
vous êtes content d'avoir pu trouver une
petite mesquinerie obstructive pour ne
pas laisser une niche aller jusqu'au
bout
tu vas la fermer
[Applaudissements]
là la séance est suspendue pour 5
minutes
[Applaudissements]